on avait les séries contre les sifflets
les sifflets mais les sifflets ils ont
été acquis sont ils imputent à parce que
il y avait les militants du front
national en fait ce sont des sifflets
des partisans de marine le pen
alors ça c'est la thèse macron c'est
qu'en fait les ouvriers sont des gens
complètement stupide pour un bond des
illettrés comme il disait
puisque ce matin il a dit marine le pen
a vu des militants sur un parking mais
qu'il leur dise ça en face l'appui je
crois qu'il y ait en ce moment sous les
sifflets et les mots difficiles qu'il
leur dise qu'il a osé dire ce matin tout
le mépris qu'ils avaient c'est qu'il ose
leur dire aussi que c'est une anecdote
qui leur arrive comme le dit sont un de
ces princes alors qu'ils seront
sécurisés de dépôt dans un griot le
porte parole à solidariser non mais je
veux dire au bout d'un an est ce que
c'est vrai que en fête nationale par les
ouvriers et par les salariés parce qu'il
est détesté là bas parce qu'il fait
partie de cette oligarchie qui crée des
délais et qui n'a rien à produire mais
oui je le ferais d'accept sont
impopulaires lorient philippot est ce
que vous pouvez confirmer ou de démentir
le fait que le front national en fait a
décidé de choisir amiens pour en faire
le symbole des délocalisations avec des
militants présents sur place depuis des
semaines des militants du front national
non c'est la direction de la foule qui a
décidé d'en faire un suivi un lieu de
délocalisation ça c'est pas nous qui
avons malheureusement pris cette
décision triste je veux dire le front
social et oui les présents depuis des
semaines sur le terrain nos militants
ils sont nos élus notre secrétaire
départemental éric richard losier
depuis des semaines et des semaines et s
qui fait ce qui explique aussi
d'ailleurs que marine le pen a été aussi
bien accueilli parce qu'il n'ya pas de
ces partis fille ciel ils savent que les
militants les élus du front ils sont là
avec eux sur le terrain depuis longtemps
et le rang et ils y sont encore là ils y
seront demain ils seront après maints
même après le départ de mike pas donc
c'est une question
la venue de manu lorient et on a
beaucoup de militants en marche alors
c'est une manipulation
qu'est-ce qu'il mène sur cette présence
cet activisme
qu'est ce qu'une manipulation d'aller
voir des ouvriers les de les soutenir
non - est-ce là une manipulation que
d'aller proposer un projet politique
pour que l'usiné ne ferme pas une taxe
de 35 %
quand vous délocalisez que vous rien
mort question monsieur fait du saas et
du fonds c'est un projet de
réindustrialisation question marine le
pen était présente ce matin à amiens
une fois jusque là elle s'était rendue
auprès de salariés en grève qui tenait
des piquets de grève
elle à faire régulièrement des sorties
usine à psa il des sorties d'usiné oui
voilà de la rue qui n'étaient pas en
grève
vous savez également que vous savez les
ouvriers ils se croient qu'ils ont mis
marina caresse quasiment 40% au premier
tour d'après les enquêtes d'opinion
parce qu'ils savent ce qui dans ce qu'il
en est voilà et bakr on doit être à 10
ou 15%
parce qu'ils savent ce qu'il en est il y
en a un qui défend la mondialisation
sauvage les délocalisations voilà il
voit la france comme une grande salle de
marché alors évidemment forcément les
ouvriers n'ont plus leur place là dedans
et puis à marine le pen qui pensent que
les conseillers du travail le matin des
ouvriers et des syndiqués de l'usiné
hier polar il a rencontré quelques
personnes mais dans un dans une salle
loin en faisant croire qu'il n'a pas le
droit d'aller sur l'usiné c'était faux
cela est un fiasco pour emmanuel macron
mais par un fiasco jeu lire artificiel
c'est un fiasco basque un problème sur
le fond il a un problème de relation
avec le monde du travail